this video is made possible by brilliant
you're gonna learn more about brilliant
later in today's video but if you would
like to learn more about them right now
go to brilliant da log forward slash by
graphics you'll also find a link in the
description below he is known as one of
the most intelligent men to have walked
the earth yet his private life was
nothing short of chaotic he was the
world's most celebrated scientist yet he
shuns the limelight he ushered in the
Atomic Age but he was a lifelong
pacifist in this week's by graphics we
delve into the contradictory life about
Einstein
Herman and Pauline Einstein a Jewish
couple married three years earlier
welcomes their first child Albert on
March the 14th 1879 six weeks after his
birth they moved from Ulm Germany to
Munich as a result of failed business
endeavors in Munich perm enjoined forces
with his brother in an electrical
engineering business which was propped
up by Pauline's parents three years
later they had their second child Maria
with the influence of his musically
talented mother
Albert started musical studies at the
age of five learning the piano and then
the violin Einstein developed an
appreciation for music at an early age
and later wrote if I were not a
physicist I would probably be a musician
I often think in music I live my
daydreams in music I see my life in
terms of music I get most joy and my
life out of music he was enrolled in a
Catholic school in 1885 switching over
to the more advanced leupold gymnasium
in 1888 which is now known as the Albert
Einstein gymnasium he proved to be
inadequate but by no means outstanding
students by 1894 the electrical
manufacturing business that Albert's
father and uncle ran was facing serious
difficulty for the last decade they had
been making DC current component tree
but now AC current was gaining
ascendancy and demand for their services
it dried up with no income coming in
Herman decided to move the family to
Italy where job prospects looked a bit
brighter
however fifteen-year-old Albert he
stayed behind to complete his schooling
in Munich now but did not enjoy his
schooling and often butted head with the
strict ropes teachers he chafed at the
strict discipline and the lack of
freedom for any creative thought the
subjects that were taught to him they
just held no interest for him except
that was for mathematics he had a
natural affinity for the subject and
quickly mastered any work that was
presented to him
from around the age of 12 and began
teaching himself advanced mathematical
concepts starting with algebra his
father engaged a tutor max Talmud but
soon now that was out thinking even him
Talmud presented the boy with a geometry
textbook he later commented Einstein had
worked through the whole book he
thereupon devoted himself to higher
mathematics soon the flight of his
mathematical genius was so high I could
not follow Einstein started teaching
himself calculus at age 12 and as a
14-year old he says that he had bastard
integral and differential calculus soon
after his families moved to Italy
Einstein forged doctors no which
convinced the principle of the loophole
gymnasium to allow him to quit school
and join his family in Italy he still
had a year to go before completing his
required schooling in his empty skies
out of attending his last year of high
school
our took an entrance exam at the Swiss
Federal Polytechnic University in Zurich
he came out with excellent results in
maths and physics but failed in every
other subject his scores in physics and
maths were so outstanding that they
caught the eye of the school's principal
he encouraged the family to send Albert
to the canton school in arauz
Switzerland in order to increase his
knowledge it was arranged to the
seventeen-year-old to stay with the
family of a professor of the school yost
vint allah during his year with the
vanillas howard fell in love with
Vince's daughter 17-year old mer even
Tula
they had a brief romance which came to
an end when Murray moved to Augsburg to
start her teaching career
[Music]
having found his academic passion Albert
applied himself to his studies in
Switzerland he passed the Swiss maturer
with outstanding grades in physics and
mathematics and then reapplied to the
Swiss Polytechnic University in Zurich
this time he passed and was admitted
into a four-year physics and mathematics
teaching diploma program it was around
this time that Albert also renounced his
German citizenship in order to avoid
compulsory military training that would
face him in a few months when he turned
Albert soon became friends with the only
girl in his class Mileva Maric they both
shared a love for science being at the
top of that class Malevich spent a
semester in Heidelberg Germany when she
was away she and Einstein wrote each
other almost everyday once she returns
their friendship it turned into a
relationship
Einstein's parents they opposed the
Union due to the difference in religion
culture and age as the couple's
relationship flourished male that
started to struggle with her studies in
1909 Stein passed the final exam but
maleva failed afterwards she worked at
raising her knowledge so that she could
retake the test it was around this time
that she found out that she was pregnant
Mileva decided to move in with their
parents in early 1902 she gave birth to
their daughter Ally Sol no one is sure
what happened to Malaya and Albert's
daughter with many thinking that she was
either adopted or died of scarlet fever
Albert struggled to find a teaching
position following his graduation this
was partly due to the fact that he had
alienated many of his tutors over the
four years of his studies he gave off
the impression that they had little of
value to impart to him and he preferred
to do his own independent study he
finally secured a job but it was one
that was totally unrelated to his course
of study and thought by his
contemporaries to be below him having
gained his Swiss citizenship he became
eligible to work for the Swiss
government he secured a position working
as a clerk in the Swiss Patent Office
for intellectual property
Einstein's job was to assess patent
applications for all manner of devices
quite a number of the patent
applications involve the transmission of
electrical signals in the
electromechanical synchronization of
time these concepts gelled with
Einsteins area of personal fascination
and served as the impetus for his
investigations exploring the nature of
light and the relationship between space
and time while his days were filled with
patent applications Einstein spent his
evenings working on his scientific
theories he started a discussion group
with a few friends Conrad Habakkuk
Thames Maurice Sullivan
he called this group the Olympia Academy
Albert's M Oliva they reunited in 1903
and they got married that same year the
couple went on to have two sons
Hans born in 1904 and Edward who arrived
in 1910
19:05 it was a turning point for Albert
Einstein over the last couple of years
he had been building a reputation as an
up-and-coming intellect among the
scientific community in April of 1905 he
completed his thesis in association with
a professor of experimental physics by
the name of Alfred kleiner Einstein
received a PhD from Zurich University
shortly thereafter during the second
half of 1905 Albert produced four
scientific papers the subjects of his
dissertations were photoelectric effect
Brownian motion special relativity and
the equivalence of mass and energy each
of them was received enthusiastically by
the Intelligencia however it was the
fourth paper that gave the world its
most famous equation
[Music]
e stands for energy M stands for mass
and C squared for the speed of light
multiplied by itself what it meant in
practical terms was that mass could be
changed into energy and vice-versa
as a result tiny packets of mass could
be converted into huge bursts of energy
the twenty six-year-old Einstein has
with the publication of his paper on the
equivalency of mass and energy it
ushered in the atomic age among those
who heaped praise upon Einstein for his
work was one of the most preeminent
quantum theorists of the day and that
was max planck from germany his backing
gave Albert instant credibility he began
receiving speaking requests from all
over Switzerland's along with offers of
teaching positions his days at the
Patent Office well they were certainly
over so this is a biography channel and
we're not diving into the depths of
Einsteins work today but if you'd like
to really get an understanding of just
what he works on you should absolutely
check out today's sponsor brilliance
brilliance are a science learning
platform that allow you to learn through
something called active learning
basically to sum this up this is kind of
the opposite of that feeling of reading
a complex paragraph about some principle
and then just having no idea what's
going on and then you probably read it
again and you'd still don't have any
idea what's going on probably not just
me it's kind of just that inability to
absorb complex information it's totally
normal it's also totally not the best
way to learn
brilliant take even something like
special relativity and make it easy to
understand they give you something super
short to read and then you immediately
apply that to a problem and just rinse
and repeat and suddenly you're
understanding all sorts of crazy stuff
that you didn't think you'd ever
understand I've used brilliant and I
think you should just go and try it out
to see how fascinating it is that you
can learn a complex subject so quickly
and easily it's just remarkable how
quickly you can grasp something whether
you want to learn about paradoxes and
space-time in their place in special
relativity useful for today's video
or maybe something completely different
like advanced stats well brilliant is
where you should do it support by
graphics they're going to brilliant org
/by graphics and let's go back to
Einstein shall we
Einstein worked a lecture circuit and
then took up a position as a lecturer at
the University of Bern in 1908
during that year he also returned to his
alma mater the University of Zurich the
university authorities were so taken
with the budding genius that they
created a position just for him as an
associate professor in their theoretical
physics department he transferred there
from Bern University in 1909 two years
later
Einstein gains a full professorship when
he took up the position at the Charles
Ferdinand University in Prague to take
up the position he had to take out
Austrian citizenship but he would only
remain in the position for 12 months
over that time he published a total of
11 scientific papers then in 1912 he
returned to the University of Zurich
where he took up a full professorship in
the theoretical physics department he
was able to work alongside his longtime
friends and collaborator
Marcel Crossman as well as teaching the
laws of thermodynamics he also lectured
on analytical mechanics that singer by
Einstein began an extramarital affair
with his first cousin Elsa lurvin tal
Einstein was not really there much for
his family putting all of his time and
energy into his work and research for
several years he had been emotionally
distant from his wife recently letters
were found that he wrote in 1910 to his
first love Marie Vince Allah in them he
professed his undying love for her ins
lamented that life that they had missed
out on together
[Music]
in 1949 Stein uprooted his family yet
again and took up a position at the
Kaiser Wilhelm Institute for physics
located at the University of Berlin it
would remain in Germany for the next 19
years and was soon appointed director of
the Institute the position gave him
professorship without teaching duties
which afforded him time to work on his
scientific studies another major draw
for the return to Germany was that it
allowed him to be closer to his mistress
Elsa towards the end of 1914 maleva
moved back to zurich with her sons after
finding out about her husband's affair
and coming to the realization that
Albert was not capable of being a family
man Einstein divorce Mileva in April of
1919 then in June he married his cousin
in 1916 Einstein published his theory of
general relativity this was a
groundbreaking achievement in the world
of physics it theorized that what we see
as the force of gravity actually results
from the curvature of space and time as
a result the earth is not actually being
pulled towards the Sun by gravity but
rather by the interaction of space and
time which dictates how the earth moves
Einstein predicted that lights from
another star would be bent by the sun's
gravity during a solar eclipse in 1919
that prediction it was confirmed the
publicity that surrounded the
confirmation of this theory it went
around the globe and for the first time
the name Albert Einstein it became
internationally known
in the early 1920s Einstein became a
celebrity among the scientific community
in America he was invited to New York to
kick off a three-week lecture tour in
April of 1921 he lectured at Columbia
and Princeton among other places of
learning he also managed to get in a
tour of the White House
Einstein's first impression of America
was a positive one shortly after his
return he published an essay called my
first impressions of America and in it
he wrote what strikes a visitor is the
joyous positive attitude to life the
American is friendly self-confident
optimistic and without envy in 1921
Einsteins popularity it reached a new
high when he was awarded the Nobel Prize
for Physics because his theories on
general and special relativity were not
yet widely accepted this award was given
for his explanation of the photoelectric
effect throughout the 1920s Albertson
else' undertook a number of
international tours that saw them being
received in such far-flung places as
Singapore Japan and Palestine in
December of 1930 he made a second trip
to the United States this time he wanted
to fly under the radar feeling that he
had received far too much attention on
his first visit but try as he may he
still found himself being overwhelmed
with office to speak and invitations to
receive awards all of them he turned
down however when he tried to slip into
New York City he couldn't avoid the
celebrity of being awarded the keys to
the city by Mayor Jim Walker when he
visited the New York Riverside shirt she
was surprised to find that the
congregants had created a life-size
statue of him he then moved on to
California where he was introduced to a
number of movie stars including Charlie
Chaplin these two men they actually
remained lifelong friends
on one occasion Chaplin and Einstein
appeared together in public to great
applause at that point Einstein turn to
Chaplin and said they are sharing us
both to this Chaplin replied they are
applauding you because none of them
understands you and applauding me
because everybody understands me
[Music]
back in Germany things were beginning to
look rather ominous with the rise of the
Nazi Party the rights of Jews they
rapidly diminished they were no longer
permitted to hold positions of authority
so Einstein was removed from his
directorship of the Kaiser Wilhelm
Institute despite being the most famous
scientist on the planet
he couldn't even teach in the local
secondary school while he was on his
overseas tours his home was raided by
the Gestapo in February 1933 Einstein
was on another tour of the United States
with Elsa without off Hitler having been
proclaimed Chancellor of Germany just a
few weeks earlier
Albert knew that there was no future for
him and the country of his birth
the couple sailed to Belgium in March
upon arrival in Antwerp Einstein went
directly to the German Consulate and
renounced his German citizenship the
Nazis later sold his boat and converted
his cottage into a Hitler Youth camp the
Einsteins rented a house in DeHaan
Belgium for a couple of months during
that time news of the Nazi book burnings
reached him it was reported that all of
Albert's writings had been consumed in
the flames a German magazine published a
list of enemies of the state and it
included Einstein alongside his name was
the caption not yet
hanged offering a $5,000 bounty on his
head in July of 1933 bine stein was
invited to London for six weeks of the
request of an old British naval officer
friends while there he had an audience
with Winston Churchill he asked for
British assistance to bring as many
Jewish scientists out of Germany as
possible Churchill was immediately
receptive over the coming years Einstein
used to sin fluids to arrange for
placements of more than a thousand
scientists in teaching positions at
universities outside of Germany on his
return to Belgium Einstein was offered a
resident scholarship at Princeton
University in October of 1933 he and
Elsa sailed again for the United States
Einstein took up the position of
Princeton University in the Institute
for Advanced Study in 1935 he was
granted permanent residency in America
he got his US citizenship in 1940 in
1935 a new tribulation arose for Hine
Stein his wife Elsa was diagnosed with
heart and kidney problems
the following year sadly she died this
was to be his biggest trial yet now
Einstein was not one to show his
emotions but it was said by a friend
Peter barky that he shed a tear after
Elsa's passing this might not sound like
but throughout that whole friendship he
had never once seen Albert cry
in 1939 a couple of young Hungarian
scientists named Leo Szilard and Eugene
Wigner discovered the science behind the
atomic bomb they tried informing those
in positions of power but they had no
influence so they were just ignored then
they decided to reach out to someone who
would have credibility with those in
high power that was when they contacted
Albert Einstein salon and Vigna
explained their theory to Einstein and
he was quick to understand the concept
salade wrote a letter to President
Roosevelt with Einsteins signature on it
the letter urged America to create the
first atomic bomb before Germany did it
has generally agreed that the addition
of Einstein's signature was a key
influencer in President Roosevelt's
adoption of the atomic bomb development
project that was known as the Manhattan
Project the US government launched the
Manhattan Project in December of 1941
amazingly Einstein's application to be a
part of the project was turned down the
reason for this was simply that he was a
German and people were worried that he
might be a spy for the Nazis on August
the 6th and August the 9th 1945 the
atomic bomb was used on the Japanese
cities of Hiroshima and Nagasaki killing
at least a hundred and twenty-nine
thousand people five months prior to his
death Albert said that his greatest
mistake in life was signing that letter
to President Roosevelt concerning the
atomic bomb he stated I made one great
mistake in my life when I signed the
letter to President Roosevelt
recommending that atom bombs be made but
there was some justification the danger
that the Germans would make them
[Music]
Einstein was never comfortable about his
fame he once said in the past it never
occurred to me that every casual remark
of mine would be snatched up and record
it otherwise I would have crept further
into my shell by the time that he was
settled into his life in America however
he realized that he was able to use his
celebrity status as a vehicle toward
promoting important causes Einstein had
been a lifelong pacifist and
humanitarian now he used his platform to
bring these causes to the fore during
the 1940s he gave his supports at the
cause of civil rights in the United
States
he considered racism to be the worst
disease in America he joins the National
Association for the Advancement of
Colored People NAACP and became friendly
with civil rights activists WEP Dubois
when Dubois was arrested in 1951
Einstein's offered to be a character
witness was enough to get the case
dismissed in 1946 he was awarded an
honorary degree from Lincoln University
in Pennsylvania which was the first in
America to award degrees to black
students he saw that racism in America
was handed down from one generation to
the next Einstein also spoke out against
anti-semitism he developed a friendship
with the first prime minister of the new
state of israel David ben-gurion
regarding prejudice against Jews in
various parts of the world he said there
are no German Jews there are no Russian
Jews there are no American Jews there
are in fact only Jews
he did not believe in a personal God who
concerns himself with the actions of
humans he did say however that I am NOT
an atheist preferring to call himself an
agnostic when asked if he believed in an
afterlife Einstein quipped no and one
life is enough for me and that life it
would end on the 17th of April 1955 at
the age of 76 he had been suffering from
internal bleeding caused by the rupture
of an abdominal aortic aneurysm which
had previously been reinforced
surgically the night before his passing
a Princeton hospital when offered
surgery Einstein said I want to go when
I want it is tasteless to prolong life
artificially I have done my share it is
time to go I will do it elegantly in a
memorial lecture in 1965 nuclear
physicist J robert Oppenheimer
summarized his impression of Einstein as
such he was almost wholly without
sophistication and wholly without weld
leanness there was always with him a
wonderful purity at once childlike and
profoundly stubborn so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
do not forget to subscribe also please
do check out our sponsor brilliant
you'll find a link to them below and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]